we are 9 31
going on a thousand
still gaining a lot of rating every game
so
uh we're provisional
and let's
play ten plus five
[Music]
and we got an 1188 with black so once
again
the premise of the speedrun is that i
play
traditional old school openings nothing
crazy and we play very very solid okay
italian
now if you're a beginner if you're in
this rating range
obviously as you know there's knight f6
and there's bishop c5 two main moves
um
if you're a beginner
going into the fried liver is a little
bit questionable unless you know the
theory so my
recommendation is to stick with bishops
e5 there's just less
tricky lines in bishop c5
and and and it's just easier to learn so
c3 is the main move
now we go knight f6 and white has d4 and
d3
d3 is what the what the big guns play
d4 is of course the old main line this
is the traditional move and this leads
to an extremely theoretical line
that we've had before in the speed run
so e takes d4c takes d4 now very
importantly we don't drop our bishop
back this allows white to steam or lost
in the center we have to give this very
important check on before
this gives us a tempo to either capture
the pawn or to strike back in the center
with d5 bishop d2
okay so
in this position
who knows what the main continuation is
for black give me the sequence and i'm
going to show you guys a cool line that
avoids the main line theory and still
equalizes
so
the main move is not knight takes c4
that's the move we're going to play
folks the main move is bishop takes d2
check
knight b takes d2
and then d5 striking in the center
unfortunately that's my game against
sevien from the u.s championship by the
way there's a four straw in that line
not a four straw
but
it's a very colorless position
but
a far more uh theoretically narrow and
in my opinion more interesting move is
knight takes e4 it looks very scary to
capture the spawn but
if you if you know the theory
you can trust that uh you're going to
get away with this move
so this is also not very well known even
by people who play the italian
okay knight c3 is already a very bad bad
reaction this this just
lets us off the hook scot-free
and not only that it gives us a
favorable trade so what should we take
the knight of the bishop
or should we take the knight with the
bishop
we should of course take the bishop i
mean
clearly taking the bishop is best he
pre-moves knight takes d2
and now we have another decision to make
clearly we can castle right we can
complete our development
or we can take on d4 we can take another
pawn
how do you make such a decision well a
lot of it is intuitive right a lot of it
is just do you feel comfortable taking
the spawn you quickly look for forks
and various
uh nasty ideas
i don't see
anything terribly nasty after knight
takes d4 because white is so passive
here on the other hand if you want to
play like a good russian schoolboy
there's nothing wrong with castling and
for the purpose of this speedrun we're
going to continue playing in sort of a
conservative fashion
and
we're going to avoid the need for our
necessary calculation we already have
one pawn
if he chooses to defend this pawn
okay so he didn't choose to defend this
one but if he did we would have also had
a very nasty check on e8
now that we've castled it's clear that
we can just take this pawn
of course now we can take
one thing i would check for do you guys
see this x-ray right the queen is
x-raying the knight just make sure that
there's no
discovered attacks that are dangerous
for instance if there was a queen here
the move knight d to e4 would have been
very nasty because it would have
simultaneously hit the queen and
established pressure on the knight
okay so there we go
now that i mentioned it we have to
choose our bishop move very carefully i
think a lot of people would be tempted
to play bishop c5
who can tell me why bishop c5 although
totally fine is a little bit inaccurate
because
of knight d to e4
winning a tempo although we can play
bishop b6 there but then the other
knight gets to d5 and we've given white
a lot of activity let's take c3 let's
simplify we're up two pawns
where do we want this knight
doesn't really matter we can play knight
c6 we can play knight e6
um we can even counter attack the bishop
with d5
uh
let's just let's play the simplest move
knight c6 i i don't really see the need
to spend a lot of time on this decision
and i think if you're watching the
speedrun
and you know you're trying to extract
the most out of it i think some people
start to overly obsess with
basic decisions like where to put the
night you spend five minutes on this and
you get into time pressure
in your mind you always have to have
this understanding which decisions are
likely to be important which are likely
to be less important this is clearly in
the other less important category now
he's given us the chance to go d5
so we will play d5 and then get this
bishop out perhaps e6 maybe queen to f6
hitting the pawn on c3 another move to
consider
but i like the development of the bishop
to e6
and bishop b6 is a classic example of
the
sort of how do i call 100 bits the
idea
that not every piece needs to be
needs to be you know distributing the
covert vaccine or climbing mount everest
um
bishop is defending d5 and f7
bishop is defending d5 and f7 doing a
perfectly fine job on e6
a move like bishop f5 would appeal to
more people
a move like bishop f5 would would appeal
to more people but
that bishop would also be a little bit
more vulnerable to moves like queen f3
yeah the bishop is sort of
a little bit aimless on f5 whereas on e6
is just
doing everything at once
okay knight f3
and now i would propose getting this
queen off of its initial square and
activating it with queen f6
and perhaps bringing the rooks to the
center
uh following that is a good idea a
thousand bits from cast planet thank you
holy smokes
rook 88 is coming
why rook ad okay so rugby one
now again queen takes c3 forces us to
calculate lines queen takes you through
rook takes b7
i i honestly don't don't see the need to
calculate it
now how should we defend this pawn
yeah b6
pros and cons generally you want to play
this move if possible against rook b1
because you're blunting the rook the
rook is biting into granite now another
favorite expression
whoa thank you for the bits
however what is the drawback of the move
b6 who can tell me
there is a clear
downside to playing b6 it
isn't important here
well it weakens the light squares but
more specifically it weakens the knight
then the knight becomes undefended so
you can see that if your king was on e8
for example this move would be very
dangerous as it stands the knight has a
perfectly good spot on a5 that it can
jump to and potentially later it can
move out to c4
so i factored that in when i played b6
in the event that you are uncomfortable
weakening your knight you can play rook
ab8 which is not ideal because it ties
down your rook
but that's an alternate way of defending
the pawn
you could we could have also played
knight a5 here by the way and then b6
that would have been
another possibility queen b3
oh this is a cool moment
i i'm positive that a lot of you are
seeing this and immediately thinking d4
but what did i say about this knight
if we play d4
white's gonna play queen a4 or queen b5
hitting the knight on c6 and guess what
we might end up losing that pawn on d4
so a much more mature move here is to
play knight a5 hitting the queen from
the side
getting the knight onto a defended
square and potentially we can start
expanding on the queen side with c5
eventually aiming to go d4 create a
passer we still have to activate our
rooks but we'll get to that
how do i know that the knight on the rim
is fine here well again
it's for two reasons first of all it's
anchored by the pawn and that's always a
good situation second of all the knight
is doing stuff
it's aiming at the c4 square
and it's controlling squares on the
queen side so
you don't have to worry about it being
on the rim
we can be five
again queen takes c3
if we look a little bit further it
allows rook e to c1
and i really don't want to give away the
c7 point i don't want to give white any
activity whatsoever
what comes to mind this queen is
annoying
let's kick it away with c6
thank you trapper city baby let's kick
it away
and you guys can see that i'm really
biasing my play toward
toward not calculating too much when
it's not necessary
and instead
focusing on making fundamentally sound
moves now
once we hit like 13 1400
now
we definitely can get away with it thank
you lord expo with a prime
why c6 over a6 because in a way c6 kind
of kills two birds with one stone
if you think about it
c6 creates a little bit of a pawn chain
maybe takes the burden off of the bishop
on e6 so later
look at that
so later ie right now we can play bishop
f5 which to be fair we would have played
even if the pawn was on c7 but right now
he can't even take on d5
that was
perfect timing
okay so
question answered
question answered
give me that rook
and
give me that pawn
no no reason not to take it
hopefully you saw that knight g5 is a
possibility
which can easily be parried with a move
g6
but don't be afraid of made in one
threats just because they're made in one
threats
um i think some people would be tempted
to play h6 here which would be fine
in in a classical game i'd probably go
rook fe-8 prioritizing the open file
over the another pawn because we're
already up
you know two pawns in an exchange
but again i'm playing very
straightforwardly here
now what is our
plan of action here well first of all
let's get control of the e file first
order of business
why would this rook because if we had
gone with the other rook then the rook
and f8 would be basically cornered it
would just have nothing to do on f8 as
it as it is we can bring the other rook
to d8 potentially to support the d5 pawn
okay h3
clearly
trading is good for us let's get the
other rook to e8 now
i'm playing faster the moves are
extremely simple
um you can ask me to repeat
any of the logic
very good practice in these situations
right what can possibly go wrong for us
we have everything protected
what's the last thing that we need for
in in order for us to breathe easy
there's one more thing i want to do
make some luft now i've talked about
this in a previous speed run so listen
this is going to be an important point
99 of people when they hear the word
luft you think of the move h6 or h3
in reality if you want to be you know
super accurate about it you always you
also have to consider a move like g6 or
g3 which in many cases is a far more
efficient and effective way to create
loft why is that
well here it doesn't matter it's
completely hypothetical because white is
no pieces left
but in general when your opponent has a
bishop of the same color as the luft
square you have to make sure that the
situation doesn't arise where you make
lift but they've got a bishop on d3
and you've wasted your time because that
square is still controlled
it's much harder even in this case to
control the g7 square
what's the downside of going g6 well it
weakens a lot more squares it weakens
these dark squares but in many cases if
your opponent doesn't have let's say a
dark sword bishop
or in this case where we're up a
gazillion points of material there's
simply no way for white to exploit that
so
especially this is very true in the end
game where
uh where making luft
you know can be
a very important operation
where you need to arrange your pawns
correctly rather than just automatically
playing h6
i actually have a great example of that
but
i'm gonna have to hunt it down it's in
this end game book that i have which i
can't even find so
i found the book
i think this is going to be a good way
to round off
okay so knight h2
[Music]
and again let's be
uh ricky one just wins the game
immediately oh yes we need to
but still
the knight's going to g4 by the way so
if we want to be really mean we could
play h5
as he's thinking i'm looking for the
examples that we don't have to waste any
time
okay queen a2
hey you know let's go h5
let's let's let's cut off all counter
play just
shut everything down no knight g4
we ain't letting the knight get
anywhere this is mastering end game
strategy
by hellston
which is a very advanced endgame book
even for me i mean it's got some
examples that are
highly convoluted
but an amazing book nonetheless
okay um g3
okay we can win this game in many
different ways we can simply push the d
pawn
um
we can also
essentially try to force a queen trade
with something like knight b3
but okay we'll push the deep one because
that's the easiest
yeah this one's over
i'm still looking i know it's in this
book okay and he resigns
so this is the game not a particularly
famous game i mean you guys might have
heard of rosentalis he's a gm
um mcnabb is also gm from scotland
and this position occurred in their game
okay so it's black to move
it's black to move
and uh
if if you get your bearings here it's
clear that black is trying to win and
white is trying to make a drop
rosentalis is up a pawn
so what move comes to mind immediately
with black
and you look at this for a couple of
seconds
and you realize that the bottom b7 is
hanging and you
your your hand
aims to make the move well rook a2 check
doesn't give anything rokey 2 check just
came back to f3 and you can repeat moves
but b6 right
but what is white's source of counter
play here if you play b6 white's just
gonna start checking you check
check
and you can't escape the checks if you
try you're going to end up losing all of
your fonts i'm just going to mop these
up
not good
so
in order to understand
rosenthal's approach first of all you
have to realize he decided to give away
the b7 pawn
because
the
uh
the extra pawn is not black's only
advantage in this position
the other source of black's advantage
is contained in the fact that white has
these extremely weak pawns right e4 e45
are very weak and the stroke on a3 is
very well placed it's cutting off the
white king
so a lot of you guys are coming up with
the move g6 this is where the fun occurs
g6 is a good move
but
the problem with g6 is that after rook
takes b7 king f8
um
let's say rook b8 check
and white gets behind the pawn y can
also go and play a move like
h4
why can't play a move like h4 and you
guys see where this is heading white's
gonna lock you in
that king is not gonna be able to to
escape its cage
so the idea is to kill two birds with
one stone we go pawn g5
creating this loft on g7 but also
freezing
white's king side pawn so that black's
king
will essentially have a pathway through
g6 and potentially to the king side
and this wins black the game this idea
it doesn't necessarily lead to a
decisive advantage
but it gives black a chance h5
um and and rosentel it ends up
outplaying him here it's a very
difficult position to defend
h4
and now g4 x glam
this creates a very weak pawn on g3 and
this is all because black played g5
here here here
sorry king e2
you need to
rug b3
rook takes a7 rook takes b5
and black ends up winning the game king
e3 rook b3
king f2 rook b2 very tricky
it should be a draw so king e3 the idea
is rook g2
king f1
and rogue back to b4 zentalis ends up
winning the g6 the e4 pawn and then he
comes around and wins the e5 pawn and
wins the game
anyways i didn't want to make too big of
a deal of this but that's an example of
basically doing two things with one move
in the end game
not exactly the same but
hopefully
you kind of see the resemblance
yeah so in the game by the way after
knight takes c4 the only thing i'll say
is that the main line here is bishop
takes before
uh knight takes b4 and now bishop takes
f7 check
king takes f7 queen b3 check winning
back the night and this leads by force
to an end game king f8 queen takes
before queen e7 white has to trade
because otherwise they're also going to
be discovered check and this is an equal
endgame according to the engines
so
that's the main line and knight takes e4
is a fully fledged alternative to bishop
takes d2 check but uh yeah the way that
he played you know giving up the second
pawn
the game was pretty much over pretty
quickly so
um i won't spend too much time analyzing
uh i think i kind of explained
everything during the game
and um
we will
end the stream for today it was a longer
stream than anticipated but i'm tired
guys i'm going to go to bed we're
definitely going to do more speed
running
later i'm going to try to stream
tomorrow
maybe even in the morning so
stay tuned thanks for hanging out and
appreciate the support
[Music]